[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de tv 78 nous sommes le jeudi 13
septembre tout de suite les titres de
cette édition
après la fin à d'autolib cet été la
question de l'avenir se pose désormais
un recours dénonçant l'arrêt brutal du
service était étudiée mardi par le
tribunal administratif de paris une
action entreprise par un collectif de
plusieurs communes franciliennes menée
par philippe brillault le maire du
chesnay est notre invité le régime de
sécurité sociale des étudiants
disparaîtra à la rentrée 2010 9 ce matin
la cpam des yvelines était présente à
lui vs qu à guyancourt pour enseigner
les jeunes sur cette évolution dans ce
journal
on vous explique ce qui change
concrètement pour les étudiants enfin
c'est le rêve de tous les clubs amateurs
aller le plus loin possible en coupe de
france et défier pourquoi pas une équipe
professionnelle ce dimanche l'ès
montigny le bretonneux et voisins fc
entretien devant cet espoir à l'occasion
du troisième tour de la compétition
avant de développer ces titres est
jacqueline gourault en visite ce matin
dans les yvelines la ministre auprès du
ministre de l'intérieur était dans les
locaux de deux communautés emmaüs à
chatou et port marly un déplacement
moins de deux mois après une polémique
sur le site de port marly quatre
compagnons avaient été emmenés à la
police de l'air et des frontières suite
à une descente des forces de l'ordre
dans les locaux de la communauté
il a fait sa rentrée le président du
conseil départemental des yvelines s'est
rendu hier mercredi au collège maryse
bastié de vélizy villacoublay
pierre bédier est revenu sur les
priorités de cette année dans les cent
trente neuf collèges privés et publics
du département
reportage de marie lehn iapichino et
nicolas landry réhabilitation et
rénovation des collèges une priorité
budgétaire pour le département des
yvelines
la collectivité va investir 430 millions
d'euros jusqu'en 2020 plusieurs
établissements sont concernés comme les
collège paul eluard de guyancourt en
reconstruction et albert einstein de
magny les hameaux en restructuration
nous avions un certain nombre d'endroits
les conditions d'enseignement étaient
pas très bonne
je peux pas dire dégradé le monstre est
exagéré mais pas très bonne
autre réforme en cours la restauration
scolaire avec une tarification unique
basé sur les revenus et la composition
des familles appliqué à partir du 1er
janvier 2019 faisant cette unification
taillefer il nous paraît nécessaire
d'avoir une unification de la
fabrication pour avoir une
homogénéisation de la qualité la
question des circuits courts aussi donc
des produits disponibles
on va essayer de d'avoir une
saisonnalité des produits d unification
rendue possible par la création d'une
société d'économie mixte à opération
unique les yvelines s'associe à un
opérateur privé pour fournir les
quelques 48 mille repas par jour dans
les collèges le département en tant
qu'institution présidera le conseil
d'administration est donc surveillera
cette société pour s'assurer que la
qualité l'écoutent
tout choix bien cadré est bien conforme
au cahier des charges
le conseil départemental désignera le
prestataire privé lors de la séance
prévue le vendredi 28 septembre prochain
un arrêt définitif depuis sept étés
autolib a pris fin officiellement le 31
juillet dernier à paris et dans les
communes franciliennes comme versailles
vélizy et le chesnay une décision prise
fin juin en raison du déficit de ce
service d'auto partage de voitures
électriques plusieurs élus franciliens
réunis en collectif dénonce une fin
brutale bon soir à philly brio bonsoir
vous êtes le maire du chesnay mer les
républicains du chesnay vous êtes à la
tête de ce collectif d'élus qui est
composée notamment des communes de
meudon versailles encore levallois
perret vous avez déposé plusieurs
recours l'un d'eux était étudié cette
semaine par le tribunal administratif de
paris
quelle réponse avait voulu alors tout
d'abord nous avons fait un recours sur
la délibération du 21 juin qui faisait
un arrêt
prématurée de la dsp de façon brutale
c'est ce que nous avons dénoncé pour
aller assez vite nous avons fait un
référé il ya eu lieu le 11 septembre
dont l'ordonnancé tombée hier et qui
déboute pour le moment notre référé
parce que le référé c'est une notion
d'urgence
donc on considère qu'il n'y a pas
d'urgence sur cette délibération par
contre nous allons avoir un certain
nombre d'autres phénomènes de recours à
d'autres recours sous la menace qu en
fait notre problème aujourd'hui c'est
plus tellement de savoir si on peut
remettre autolib en route les gens les
utilisateurs aujourd'hui ont été lésés
malheureusement tout est démonté et
maintenant c'est surtout des
conséquences financières et les
conséquences financières c'est à nous
aussi de pouvoir défendre des intérêts
de nos administrés et c'est là où sur le
fond nous allons avoir de la matière et
le genre du référé nous avons eu quand
même beaucoup d'informations de la part
du syndicat qui nous a démontré bien que
tout était occultée et c'était la ville
de paris qui avait la main sur saute
syndicats et le contestons violemment sa
qualité de gestion c'est tout cela les
enjeux sont vraiment millions d'euros et
notre devoir d'élus est aussi de
défendre nos administrés on précise que
ce syndicat c'est le syndicat mixte
autolib vélib métropole voilà qui qui
était à l'origine de cette délibération
dont vous parliez 7 à l'heure et sans
vie libre parce qu'on peut se demander
si ce sera pas le deuxième étage de la
fusée
d'ailleurs même le président du tribunal
sera tiff a demandé si c'était pas le
prochain sujet de reprocher ça sera à
suivre en tout cas vous disiez des
millions d'euros sont en jeu 250
millions d'euros de dettes laissées ça
c'est l'ardoisé laissée par groupe
bolloré qui gérait autolib et combien
aujourd'hui
comptant aujourd'hui et combien on nous
demande de payer justement au chesnay
les deux n'en savons rien puisque
justement c'est tout le débat
qu'est ce qu'on va nous demander puisque
en fait le déficit était prévu jusqu'en
2015 nous avions gagné à partir de 2015
un peu d'argent 2016 s'est dégradée
c'est quand même curieux que la
dégradation à fin 2016 correspondent à
la fermeture des voies sur berge en
septembre 2016 dont on voit très bien
que les conditions de circulation ont
été une première mesure le groupe
bolloré nous alerter dessus 2017
nous devions prendre des décisions une
anodine a été réalisée nous n'avons
jamais connu la teneur sauf en 2018
rien n'a été proposé au comité pour
modifier c'est tout cela qu'on dénonce
car nous aurions très bien pu limiter le
déficit sera inéluctable on pouvait
arrêter ce déficit est et continuer
puisque les bleus mandé comme argent et
ce script est ce que ce n'est pas
éventuellement ce qui aurait été à payer
au terme de la délégation donc tout ceci
s'est fait dans l'omerta totale dans la
précipitation totale et c'est ce que
nous dénonçons et surtout que nous
voulons voir parce que nous avons un
prochain comité
dans quelques jours on va certainement
nous proposer des protocoles financiers
comme on nous l'a proposé 11 janvier le
11 juillet où on nous a demandés déjà un
million neuf
or conventionnement vous parliez de la
manif tout al heure de paris de la ville
de paris dans ce dossier en juin canton
on parlait déjà de ce dossier vous
parliez d'intenter une action en justice
contre la maire de paris contre la ville
de paris contre la maire de paris anne
hidalgo est ce que c'est toujours
d'actualité
est ce qu'il y avait bien un certain
nombre de points qui peuvent nous
interroger sur une responsabilité deux
personnes voire de pénale bien sûr et
donc tout ceci nous sommes en train de
le regarder donc c'est un ensemble de
démarches que nous faisons un est-ce
qu'on peut remettre en route autolib a
priori non 2 qu'est ce que nous allons
payer c'est sur les recours que nous
allons faire 3 qu'est responsable c'est
ce que nous allons voir par rapport au
pénal c'est un service qui fonctionnait
bien dans la ville du chesnay quel
retour vous aviez des habitants
apprécient s'il y avait cinq stations y
avait plein de jeunes qui n'avaient pas
de voiture qui s'en servait bien sûr que
tous leurs pendant les grèves de la sncf
est allé plus une voiture sur les
parkings d'une alternance et d'un
système qui fonctionnait parfaitement
bien propre partager pourquoi on
l'arrêté il ya aussi la question des
places laissées vacantes aujourd'hui par
par autoliv versailles a par exemple
choisi de réintégrer ces places dans le
domaine public ça veut dire qu'on peut
aujourd'hui de nouveau s'y garer quelle
décision veut prendre le chesnay alors
nous avons décidé en bureau des maires
il ya quelques jours avec françois de
mazières le maire de versailles de
mutualiser l'ensemble de place dans
l'ensemble de nos communes pour
peut-être étudier une possibilité pour
les voitures propres pour les voitures
électriques et le syndicat sigeif
électrique est en train de nous proposer
des solutions donc que pour le moment on
utilise nos places pour pas les perdre
alors qu'il en manque
oui comme le fait versailles et que ce
soit une solution définitive
non c'est à dire qu'il pourrait y avoir
d'autres services proposés grâce à grâce
à ces places profiter de ces places pour
proposer d'autres services aux adhérents
qui ont peut-être profiter de tout ce
qui peut être les free floating il va
falloir que effectivement on remette en
place
tout ceci pour éviter que les voitures
stationnent à peu n'importe où et puis
surtout privilégier les voitures
électriques des voitures propres
il faut aider toutes celles et ceux qui
savent et 6 et puis va falloir apprendre
certainement à se déplacer autrement
avec des vae des vélos électriques nous
ça c'est une nouvelle démarche
comme vous le savez pas modifié les
bornes électriques qui sont pour non
compatible qu'avec ses véhicules
autolib pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
recharger tous les véhicules électriques
s'est délecté mantoue
terrey de la démarche du syndicat de
sigef qui va nous aider justement à
mettre en conformité des bornes mais
semble-t-il sans trop de complexité sans
trop de difficultés dont je dis à la
population voilà nous les maires on est
en train de se bouger pour ce que vous
n'avez plus puissent revenir peut-être
sous une forme différente mais on vous
oublie pas et surtout n'oubliez pas
votre portefeuille
qu'est ce que vous espérez de toutes ces
actions lancées par votre collectif il
ya j'imagine défendre déjà l'intérêt des
usagers
c'est tout ce qui ne bouge pas donné
quitus tous ceux qui contestent auront
la possibilité de négocier et la suite
du coup qu'est ce qu'on peut espérer
pour la suite pour le chesnay sur sur ce
dossier ce que vous avez le chesnay et
les autres communes nous allons le
savoir dans quelques jours au prochain
comité syndical de d'eau libre et nous
dirons au décours de ce comité
ce que nous en pensons qui à mon avis va
aller dans le même sens que celui que
nous avons vécu le maire tard mesdames
et messieurs aujourd'hui c'est comme ça
à vous de payer terminé on a entendu
parler de le répète les parisiens parce
que je pense que les parisiens ils vont
payer très cher mais bon ils sont
peut-être plus à ça près on a entendu
revenir les noms des groupes psa et
renault pour éventuellement reprendre
ses services ça vous ne vous n'avez pas
du tout eu vent tandis que tout s'est
passé dans la mairie de paris ce qui
montre bien que tout se fait dans le
bureau de madame hidalgo et on peut se
demander même si elle n'est pas déjà
fait ça avant de demander la rupture de
la délégation pour faciliter peut-être
de nouveaux systèmes
affaire à suivre donc merci philippe
briand était avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes le maire les républicains de
la commune du chesnay c' est la sécurité
sociale étudiante c'est bientôt terminé
la cpam des yvelines était présente ce
jeudi à lui vécu pour informer les
jeunes de ce changement ce régime
spécifique disparaîtra totalement en
septembre 2019 mais une partie de la
réforme est d'ores et déjà appliquée en
cette rentrée pour les nouveaux
étudiants explications avec ce sujet
d'isabelle karisko enterrer la sécurité
sociale étudiante
jusqu'ici elle était gérée en france par
les mutuelles étudiantes qui étaient
chargés de les affiliés à la sécurité
sociale
désormais tous les étudiants dépendront
du régime général
comme c'était le cas durant leur
scolarité jusqu'au lycée pas de raison
de paniquer il n'y aura aucune démarche
à faire concernant les nouveaux
étudiants pour la rentrée 2010 8 rien ne
change il faudra simplement qu'ils
s'assurent que leurs coordonnées
personnelles sont bien à jour
éventuellement créer un compte ameli si
ça n'est pas déjà fait et puis donc
bien bien s'assurer que ils mettent leur
carte vitale à jour il reste sur le
compte des parents et les bascules se
feront en cours d'année automatiquement
les étudiants déjà inscrits dans une
mutuelle étudiants pour rien ne change
ils n'auront pas à verser la cotisation
non plus ils sont exemptes et la bascule
se fera pour eux l'année prochaine à la
rentrée 2010 9
l'ancien cotisation annuelle à la
sécurité sociale d'un montant de 217
euros est supprimé c'est une
contribution obligatoire unique de 90
euros qui la remplace elle est destinée
à financer la vie du campus et les
boursiers en seront exonérés
j'étais directement affiliée à la
sécurité sociale ou jettent l année
dernière donc ça change rien pour moi
pour moi c'était moins cher je trouve
que c'est que du positif
à la rentrée 2010 9 l'ancien système
aura entièrement disparu les mutuelles
étudiantes elles ne cesseront pas
totalement leurs activités puisqu'elle
continuerons de proposer des
complémentaires santé aux étudiants qui
souhaiteront y adhérer le sport dans un
peu plus de 10 jours c'est la ryder cup
à saint quentin en yvelines le golf
national va accueillir les meilleurs
joueurs mondiaux
parmi eux dans la sélection américaine
un nom qui parle à beaucoup
tiger woods la légende de la discipline
n'avait plus participé à la compétition
depuis 2012 michael et demi d'euros et
patrick jacques de dixmude un tigre golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines le
capitaine de la sélection américaine jim
furyk a décidé de sélectionner tiger
woods l'homme aux 14 tournois du grand
chelem pour la ryder cup 2018 fin
septembre une invitation attendu après
le bel été du golfeur sur les meilleurs
tournois mondiaux
il finit fille née dans l'est dans les
six premiers à l'open britannique il est
deuxième à lui à ce budget il est
toujours devant quoi ce cirque en
randonnée tiger et revenir aux affaires
en plus on sent un joueur en tout cas
il paraît beaucoup plus détendue
beaucoup plus ouvert on sent un joueur
qui est qui et qui est moins qu'ils
aient moins de tournées vers lui un peu
plus vers les autres et je pense que ça
a dû penchés également dans la balance
dans le dans le choix du capitaine
américain tiger woods au golf national
ce n'est pas une première le golfeur
avait participé aux championnats du
monde amateurs en 1994 sur le parcours
de l'albatros avec ip américaine avait
gagné à le score par équipes mais il
n'avait pas finir les premiers méfaits
voilà un beau tournoi mais pas fini
premiers à première vue individuel
au-delà de l'aspect sportif la venue du
golfeur de 42 ans absent d'une ryder cup
depuis 2012 devrait doper les audiences
sur le circuit américain le nombre de
téléspectateurs et multiplier par deux
camps le tigre et sur le green
quand le voir sur les tournois qui joue
sur lesquels il se remet en mouvement en
forme
le dernier a eu à speed g kiwi fini
deuxième où ils ont battu tous les
records d'audience
tiger woods over nationale c'est un rêve
je pense et on pouvait pas rêver mieux
si les statistiques médiatiques sont du
côté de tiger woods sur le terrain la
ryder cup ne sourit pas aux golfeurs en
sept participations le sportif ne l'a
remporté qu'une seule fois en 1999 elle
fait rêver les footballeurs amateurs la
coupe de france de football revient ce
week-end troisième tour au programme ce
dimanche et deux clubs de saint quentin
en yvelines tenteront est de se
qualifier pour l'échelon suivant bonsoir
antoine ristorcelli êtes le président du
voisin football club alors votre équipe
se déplace dans les hauts-de-seine à
sèvres qui évolue au même niveau que
vous en départementale 2 districts
rencontre à 14h30 au stade des fontaines
un deuxième invité avec nous en plateau
jérémy fans et bonsoir vous êtes le
responsable technique football à 11 à la
hes montigny le bretonneux football
montigny reçoit choisy-le-roi ce
dimanche à 14h30 au stade de la cool
c'est un club du val de marne qui évolue
trois divisions au-dessus de montigny en
régionale 2 petit tour de table pour
commencer on va commencer avec vous
jérémy
que représente ce troisième tour de
coupe de france pour vous est ce que
c'est une compétition qui vous fait
rêver
une compétition qui intéresse toujours
les joueurs rêver je sais pas je sais
qu'ils sont très motivés en tout cas
pour cette rencontre
ils savent très bien ils sont quand même
conscients qu'ils vont pas aller au bout
donc pour eux c'est vraiment que du
plaisir ils prennent ça comme un petit
bonus
et puis ils vendront chèrement leur peau
sur ce match là antoine pour le voisin
fc ça représente quoi d'être au
troisième tour de cette coupe de france
c'est exactement pareil
c'est la troisième fois qu'on va pouvoir
atteindre ce niveau avec notre équipe
senior on a fait un parcours en
gambardella donc c'est la coupe de
france pour les pour les u19 l'année
dernière on est allé en cour fédérale à
tour donc on va essayer les cliques et
seigneurs de reproduire le même le même
schéma et l'objectif pour tous les
joueurs c'est d'aller chercher ce qu'on
appelle des maillots puisqu'autour
prochain la fédération française de
football offre les maillots et ça c'est
le graal absolu pour tous les joueurs de
pouvoir garder ça le portier
entraînement l'avant dans les armoires
de montrer aux enfants alors c'était le
diable pour pour vos deux clubs le
premier tour de coupe de france c'est
jouer avant les vacances d'été racontez
nous un peu comment ça s'est passé
qui avez vous affrontez comment se sont
déroulées ces deux premiers tours en toi
je commence à nous on a fait un sans
faute à l'extérieur on a fait deux
premiers tours extérieur ou hot ou
encore à l'extérieur on espère pouvoir
recevoir à domicile après une fois donc
un petit séjour dans 95 à
jouy-le-moutier où on a gagné 2 0 et
dans le fin fond de 91 à vis moison le
premier tour sur un superbe terrain ça
aurait pas d'ironie dans la stabiliser
non c'est très bien mais voilà on
appelle dans le jargon un champ de
patates on peut lire ouais je pense
qu'ils avaient répété les patates j'ai
pas très longtemps et futurs du côté de
de montigny comment ça s'est déroulé ses
deux premiers tours également de deux
tours à l'extérieur un peu dans les
mêmes conditions c'est un peu le
folklore de la coupe de france au début
au conte était dans le 91 à saint vrain
au départ donc match compliqué terrain
compliqué une petite petite ambiance
folk lo et deuxième match contre un
adversaire 2
du même calibre donc ça nos gens nos
gens sur marne le coup on est passé à un
petit peu à la dure mais les joueurs
avaient à coeur pour le dernier match de
la saison de s'offrir ce troisième tour
en septembre et se qualifier pour un
quatrième tour qu'est ce que ça
représenterait antoine disais tout à
l'heure il ya ces fameux maillot qui
arrivent les maillots qu'on voit à la
télé les maillots de la coupe de france
est-ce que aussi en terme financier
peut-être qu'il ya un apport pour le
club
l'apport financier il existe mais
beaucoup plus tard ma connaissance ce
serait plutôt aux alentours du 7e tour
donc là la route est longue pour nous on
a de l'espoir mais c'est vrai que les
maillots c'est quelque chose d'important
pour les joueurs nous ça fait longtemps
qu'on n'a pas fait une belle aventure en
coupe de france où une dizaine d'années
on était allé au 6e tour donc charge à
l'équipe de johan à sophie de réaliser
un bel exploit dimanche il ya un côté
forcément antoine prestigieux symbolique
aussi la coupe de france les clubs
amateurs y participer peuvent aller
pourquoi pas s'il continue titiller des
clubs professionnels ça sera plus tard
peut-être c'est le seul moment où on a
la possibilité puisqu'on est club de 18
on a la possibilité peut-être au
prochain tour de jouer contre un gros
club de national pour nous ce serait
déjà énorme et pouvoir faire une fête à
la maison que dans ce cas là on
recevrait au prochain tour et comment on
aborde dans vos différents clubs est ce
que quand on en parle aux joueurs on en
parle comme un bonus qui pourrait
apporter je ne sais pas un surplus
d'expérience pour cette saison est ce
que ça un réel objectif d'aller le plus
loin possible dans cette compétition
jérémy on leur propose un peu comme un
challenge un peu là une façon de
s'étalonner à des équipes une équipe
plus forte pour nous et puis même un
petit coup de projecteur sur l'équipe
certainement un peu plus de monde dans
la dans la tribune ou peut-être faire
venir un peu une plus de membres de leur
famille est vraiment comme j'ai dit au
début de l'interview prendre ça comme un
bonus à prendre du plaisir
paradoxalement c'est avec cette semaine
ils sont très calmes et se prépare
sereinement veut dire des bénac des
banalités mais ils sont rien à perdre
c'est ça c'est un plus un gros plus d'y
participer ça amène de l'expérience peut
être des matches à enjeu on va aller se
frotter à des équipes là ça sera pas le
cas pour voisins ce week-end mais des
équipes mieux classées dans des dans des
championnats plus plus élevé enfin
pourquoi pour voisin l'objectif de cette
saison c'est clairement la montée en
1 pour la saison prochaine on prépare de
façon classique tous les débuts de
championnat avec un stage de prérentrée
où c'est un week-end qui est consacré
aux seniors où on fait repas le midi il
fonde beaucoup de physique et on prépare
comme ça le premier de faire un
troisième tour de coupe de france est le
premier de la saison pour pouvoir
effectivement être assez performant mais
c'est une pression apportez vos deux
clubs évoluent au niveau départemental
de district en tout cas pour l'équipe
une senior jérémy en parler pour
montigny séparés par et comment du côté
de voisins cette semaine juste avant ce
troisième tour de coupe de france c'est
un match à l'extérieur il faut peut-être
le préparer différemment que commencer
comment l'entraîneur fait partie de ces
joueurs et ça commençait à ce que pareil
dimanche dernier puisque c'était le
premier match de championnat et on avait
fini sur une victoire donc c'était bien
on a eu une blessure d'un joueur and
haas dont j'en profite pour lui de
passer le bonjour puisqu'il a une
blessure à la cheville
l'objectif de l'équipe ça va être de
pouvoir faire en sorte qu and haas
puisse rejouer sur un match de coupe de
france
et malheureusement ça sera qu au stade
de france puisqu'il est payé pour qui la
saison
il est bizarre tout là c'est donc on
espère qu'il va vouloir rapidement mais
là ces établissements en tout cas
jusqu'au bout je veux le psg en finale
oublier antoine vous c'est pardon j'irai
me je comprends les deux noms jérémy du
côté de montigné on est on est assez
serein même si il ya quand même trois
divisions d'écart entre les entre les
deux clubs dimanche voit vraiment un peu
comme une fête
coup de projecteur sur l'équipe et puis
nous le coach adverse c'est à dire que
c'est sammy traoré donc c'est un grand
professionnel qui est passé quand même
par le psg avoue que ce sera un petit
peu l'attraction du dimanche est
vraiment niveau vraiment c'est donc on
n'a rien à perdre si on arrive à faire
l'exploit reparlera nous sera une bonne
chose au tour suivant sera très bien si
jamais on perdait contre une équipe
trois divisions au dessus vous n'aurez
pas à rougir la préparation particulière
sur les tirs au but ça peut être un
scénario possible du match voilà je
suppose que le coach va travailler ça
cette semaine à l'entraînement et puis
après on va pas dévoiler à tous bien sûr
cette astuce un appel à lancer peut-être
aux supporters vous jouerez à donner
quelques affiches on demande vraiment à
tout le monde
de se déplacer en masse au stade on va
être quoi les accueillir et on espère
leur proposer un beau spectacle
est ce que voisin va emmener avec le
club de bouazza va emmener avec lui dès
les supporters à sèvres alors on va pas
loin de bus comme on l'avait fait en
gambardella l'année dernière puisque
c'est à côté
mais effectivement on va se déplacer en
masse pour les supporter les a donc fait
qu'il phare est bon vous souhaite bonne
chance en tout cas pour ce troisième
tour de coupe de france je le rappelle
au programme ce dimanche voisins se
déplace dans les hauts-de-seine à 16
rencontres à suivre à 14h30 c'est au
stade à des fontaines et montigny le
bretonneux reçoit choisy-le-roi au stade
de la couldre le coup d'envoi est fixé
également à 14h30 pour le portrait de la
semaine direction le sentier des
maréchaux en vallée de chevreuse le site
et sa carrière était particulièrement
prisé autrefois par la capitale pour sa
pierre de grès un artiste potier jean
guével s'est inspiré des lieux pour son
travail réalisé dans le cadre de
l'opération aux artistes le patrimoine
une rencontre signée jules police situé
entre les communes de senlis est cerné
le sentier des maréchaux est un lieu de
la vallée de chevreuse bien connue des
promeneurs
cependant son histoire est un peu moins
cette carrière permettant de fournir
paris en pavés jusqu'en 1930 était le
lieu de travail mais également de vie
des nombreux carrier habitants cerner
ces temps par son passé que son rapport
à la terre que ce lieu a touché jean
govelle pour le projet aux artistes le
patrimoine du parc naturel régional
j'ai tout de suite eu un tilt avec le
lieu qui était donc le le sentier
d'aider des maréchaux à cause de la
carrière de grès monsieur gentil très à
l'aise et je suis je
j'ai cherché à voir ce que je pourrais
faire là dedans je me suis lancé plus
tôt dans la réalisation de deux fûts
auquel je vais donner l'apparence de
dudu de la roche de la de l'arbre 2d
d'éléments naturels tels qu'ils peuvent
être dans le dans la carrière le chemin
sur lequel on va mettre ces objets
étaient le chemin qui était emprunté
deux fois par jour par les carriers
quand ils allaient travailler quand il
en revenait donc ça c'est encore plus de
sens je dirais de de montrer un peu des
témoignages des histoires qui sont liées
de gens qui arrivent et qui sont mariées
ici qui sont installés on fait des
enfants
une migration c'est l'histoire d'une
migration d'une intégration pour
transcrire ses souvenirs j'en veux
façonner des objets sonores rappelant
l'ambiance qui pouvait régner dans ces
carrières au début du 20e siècle mais
également rendre hommage par différents
types de céramique
il y aura
deux types de décors il ya un décor qui
va figurer là les éléments
naturelles comme la roche sous les
arbres et caetera et des éléments qui
vont être des photos en fait qu'on va
faire fondre sur l'émail
pour moi ça marchera si les gens
s'approprient vraiment le
ce qu'ils voient est ce qu'ils entendent
et si ça leur renvoie à la d'autres
choses pourquoi pas un imaginaire
minérale mais aussi nature aussi plus
méditatif avec le son c'est autour de ça
que les gens s'agrègent et vont venir y
greffer leur propre leurs propres
souvenirs
un travail avant tout sensorielle qui
cherchent donc à nous emmener dans une
époque un lieu une ambiance de façon
presque participative une installation
que vous pourrez découvrir du 6 octobre
au 30 décembre est ainsi ressentir toute
l'histoire de cette carrière avant de se
quitter n'oubliez pas ce week end ce
sont les journées du patrimoine
retrouver à la sélection des sorties à
saint quentin en yvelines c'est dans le
7-8 loisirs présenté par marylène
iapichino dans quelques minutes elle le
journal de la rédaction on touche à sa
fin retrouvez nous sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]